ابدا معك وليد العمري ولنتحدث عن سير
المعارك في الشمال والجنوب في ظل حديث عن
ان هناك انسحابات في سياق اقتصادي ولكنه
ليس السياق الوحيد بالتاكيد فما الذي يروى
فيما يتعلق
بهذه الخسائر وكذلك المعارك في الشمال
والجنوب ليس فقط من ضمن البيانات الرسميه
للجيش ولكن ايضا في الاوساط المختلفه
الاسرائيليه بما يتعلق وشمال قطاع غزه اخر
ما حرر بهذا الشان هو وان الجيش يتحدث عن
ان قواته اقتربت من اتمام سيطرتها على حيي
التفاح والدرج و في مدينه غزه وانه بذلك
سيكون قد اتم سيطرته الكامله على شمالي
القطاع وعلى الانفاق هناك وان هذه المساله
سيترتب عليها اعاده انتشار قواته التي بدا
بها بالامس وامس الاول بسحبها من المناطق
السكنيه الى خارجها لكن المعارك ما تزال
ضاريه ووفق كافه المصادر في منطقه الجنوب
وتحديدا في مناطق خانيونس وداخل منطقه
خانيونس حيث تعمل سبعه الويه عسكريه
اسرائيليه في هذه المنطقه والتصريحات
وايضا المعلومات المتسربه تقول بان
المعارك قويه جدا وانه كان بالامس وخلال
24 ساعه الماضيه قد اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي
عن ان نحو 45 من جنوده وضباطه قد نقلوا
الى المستشفيات جرحى في بعد معارك طاحنه
في هذه المناطق كافه على الصعيد الاقتصادي
بدا الاسرائيليون يتحدثون وايضا بنك
اسرائيل عن خسائره كبيره جدا وان هذه
الحرب تكلفتها قد تصل الى 210 مليار دولار
وهذا ما يشمل ليس فقط التكلفه العسكريه
وانما ما انما ما يترتب عليها ايضا على
القطاع المدني الاسرائيلي في حال
استمرارها لفتره طويله جدا هذه الامور
مجتمعه وايضا انعكاساتها على قضيه مساله
الاسرى الاسرائيليين في قطاع غزه الذين
يساو ذووهم واقربائهم الشك بان الحكومه
الاسرائيليه برئاسه نتنياهو لم تعد معنيه
كثيرا بامرهم اي بان قضيتهم لا تتصدر
الاولويات وفي اجتماع المجلس الحربي
الليله الماضيه كان الاسرائيليون كانت قد
قدم رئيس المساد تقريرا وخلص هذا المجلس
في اجتماعه الى ان ها المفاوضات بخصوص
قضيه ابرام صفقه تبادل اسرى جديده عالقه
لا تشهد اي تقدما والقوا المسؤوليه على
حركه حماس التي قالوا بانها مصممه على وقف
اطلاق النار وان اسرائيل ترفض ذلك ولا
تستطيع الاستجابه الان الاخبار الاخيره
التي وردت عن المصادر الاسرائيليه هو ان
هناك وفدان احدهما لحماس والاخر لاسرائيل
متواجدان في العاصمه المصريه القاهره في
محاوله لتحريك هذا الملف لكن لا يبدو
بالافق انه سيتم تسجيل اي اختراق قريب الى
هذا كله واضح من المعلومات التي تتناقلها
وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه وتصريحات
المسؤولين الاسرائيليين الى ان في ذهن
الحكومه الاسرائيليه مخطط للبدء بتسليم
بعض المناطق في شمالي قطاع غزه لممثلين عن
العشائر والحمائل كما تسميهم وذلك ليقوموا
بالاجراءات المدنيه مثل نقل وتوزيع
المساعدات ولكن وفق خطه يشرف عليها جهاز
الامن العام الاسرائيلي الشباك بمعنى ان
اسرائيل تعود للتفكير بان تشغيل ما كان
يعرف في بدايه ثمانينات القرن الماضي وفشل
وهي روابط القرى من اناس متعاونين معها او
ذوي مصالح تعتقد انهم سيخدمون مصلحتها
وذلك في اطار جهدها للعمل على تصفيه وجود
قضيه شعب وتحويلها لقضيه حمائله وعشائره
فقط بالاضافه الى هذا تصريحات نتنياهو
وتصريحات سموتريتش وكذلك بنكبر وما كان قد
تسرب منذ بدايه هذه الحرب عن التهجير واضح
ان في ذهنهم خطه موضوعه لاجبار الغزيين
على الهجره وايضا للعوده لبناء مستوطناتهم
في قطاع غزه هذا ما تشير اليه تصريحاتهم
الثلاثه نتنياهو قال بان انه ليس هناك
قرار بالسماح للمواطنين الغزيين بالعوده
الى الشمال و سموتريتش من ناحيته قال بانه
سيقدم قريبا مشروعا لاعاده الاستيطان في
قطاع غزه وبن كفير قال بان هذا يشير الى
فكره جيده وتستحق ان يتم تنفيذها وكان
وزير الحرب الاسبق ليبرمان قد دعا الى
تحطيم وهدم ما يعرف بمحور فيلادلفيا هذا
الشريط الفاصل بين قطاع غزه ومصر من اجل
اجبار المواطنين على الهجره الى الجانب
المصري